The past has come back to haunt these protesters in the South Korean capital, Seoul.
"We condemn the government", says this protesting relative.
The remaining link to many long dead victims...
...of Japan's bloody occupation of the Korean Peninsula.
They're demanding direct compensation from Japanese companies...
...and a fresh apology from Tokyo.
Japan normalized ties with South Korea in 1965...
...after Japanese companies apologized for enslaving hundreds of thousands of Koreans...
...during Tokyo's brutal 35 year colonial rule.
Over the years, Japanese companies compensated an estimated 800 million dollars...
...or 7.2 billion dollars in today's money,...
...which Seoul diverted to development projects...
...carried out by major South Korean companies that would transform the country...
...into a tech hub over two decades.
But the Tokyo Seoul deals soured in 2018,...
...when South Korea's Supreme Court ordered two Japanese companies,...
...Nippon Steel and Mitsubishi Heavy Industries...
...to compensate former Korean forced laborers or their relatives...
...in violation of the 1965 agreement,...
...leading to a new economic and political standoff with Japan.
Which prime minister Yoon has now resolved with his government's announcement.
Japanese foreign minister, Yoshimasa Hayashi,...
...says Tokyo appreciates the South Korean announcement as a step to restore ties.
But Japan still maintains that the South Korean announcement...
...does not require contributions from Japanese companies.
That position angers South Koreans still connected to a past...
...from where most survivors are dead or dying.
Ali Mustafa, TRT world.